[Music]
thursday pft
ot before we cut chris sims loose for
the weekend his three-day weekend he can
go home and
celebrate his son's birthday with him
have a little relaxing
evening and you know it's not and i give
you a hard time i know you keep working
i know you keep paying attention to
football we're getting closer and closer
and you'd be working hard this weekend
if we had pre-season games you'd be
watching games every night
it's really is getting into a strange
phase in august
where they haven't even started hitting
yet
and in any other year we'd be getting
ready to take in
16 preseason games over the course of
the next four days oh i know it's really
one of my
favorite weekends of the year it can
drive you crazy because you're trying to
watch everything and do that and i know
last year
we were sitting there on you know our
apple tv nfl app and doing all that
trying to watch
games and we'd be texting each other and
doing all that i can still remember us
in the first preseason game i have a
vivid memory of going
us going back and forth we saw one drive
from kyler murray and we said
you know what he belongs he's kind of
good i think he's going to be a star
i'm going to miss that tonight you know
and throughout the weekend that's what i
get excited for but
at least everything is looking good in
football the you know the coveted
testing it's all going in the right
direction
and i'm just keeping my fingers crossed
yeah think of what this is going to do
for the anticipation
of four weeks from tonight and then
three days later when the games
start we haven't had an appetizer we
haven't had a sneak preview
we don't know what to expect when the
teams line up we also don't know what to
expect when it comes to covet 19. even
though everything looks good for now
the testing has gone well the numbers
are low chris we talked during pft live
today about this notion that the
commissioner
may have an advisory committee of
outside
people not members of the competition
committee because there may be a
conflict of interest
so it would be other people who help him
decide
when to shut a team down when to
postpone a game when to cancel a game
when to take action
if he deems action is necessary given
that
one or two teams in a given game are
depleted
at a certain position group or just
don't have enough healthy players to
dress 46
and and we talked during the show and
let's revisit that and let's hammer that
point
yeah i don't like the idea of having an
escape hatch
you you get 46 guys ready to play period
and if you don't have 46 healthy guys
you get more they're gonna have 16
practice squad players any of them one
two all the way up to 16 can be
activated
to the roster on game day up to 90
minutes before kickoff
and if and if 16 is not enough have more
and if you need to have rosters of
players who aren't connected to any team
that are kept in game shape so you can
backfill those 16 if the outbreak takes
away your entire practice squad
do that do everything you have to do to
make sure there's going to be enough
players
so this conversation of whether or not
you shut down a game
never happens it's never even been
considered when a team is ravaged with
injury
it's always you know believe that you're
going to get guys ready
right and if you got a bunch of guys
injured and you get the crap kicked out
of you that's life that happens in
football yeah so whether it's an injury
or whether it's an infection it
shouldn't matter
yeah well no i mean i i'm with you in a
lot of ways but you know
of course as we both have said many
times this is a different year
you know so we don't know what to expect
and
the the one thing i'll say and you know
i've been beating this drum from kind of
the start here
is if the 16 guys on the practice squad
and maybe you being able to sign a few
other guys
stops you from fielding a team on sunday
sorry you lose
you lose you're so that's part of the
game this year
can you handle the pandemic in the virus
it's part of it
it's weird is it fair i don't know yeah
maybe not but that's just the way it is
and that's why i don't i don't like that
that we're gonna give this wiggle room
and
i mean rescheduling games or having
uneven schedules i really wish the nfl
would go no
hey team a you're healthy and ready to
go team b
you have an outbreak and can't feel the
team sorry team b that's an l
big l you lost you lost sorry that's
just the way it is
now you know if they're not willing to
do that
then i do think the committee is
somewhat necessary
yes to maybe just sit there and
have some football thoughts for a guy
like roger goodell who's not a football
player not a coach a gm
anything like that you know he handles
business so he doesn't know
realistically all what it takes
you know to get a team ready or what is
needed to feel the team on a sunday
so i do think it'd be nice to have yeah
some uh you know so-called
experts ex coaches ex players be a part
of that conversation
to maybe just throw ideas around too you
know again
we know a lot of there's a lot of smart
coaches in football some of these ex
players and ex-coaches talk to these
smart players or smart coaches out there
and i'm sure they get good ideas thrown
at them all the time and
you know i understand it from that
standpoint i guess is what i'm saying
but i think if you lose to covid you
lose the game that's
my take yep and i don't like the idea of
a committee that would determine case by
case or advise case by case on what the
commissioner should do
i think that the competition committee
should devise
standards now that that if there is
going to be
some threshold that results in games not
being played
you identify it now but here's the
problem
they don't like to engage in foresight
because they're not good
at engaging in foresight and what they
tried to do last year with
instant replay for past interference
calls and non-calls replay review for
past interference calls and non-calls
that that made them even more concerned
about trying to
prospectively predict things and create
standards
so they'd rather just decide case by
case one at a time
when should we go when should we not go
and i don't like that there needs to be
standards
there needs to be consistency chris and
it can't be
well you know what this is just one of
the ten games being played at one
o'clock eastern on sunday
we can go ahead and postpone this one
but you know what the prime time monday
night game
we we better go ahead and find a way to
play that yeah that's not going to be
good for anybody right
i'm afraid that that's going to be one
of the decision
uh of factors that drive the outcome
you know what is the impact of not
having this game
on the broader broadcasting model we can
do without a one o'clock game on sunday
we can't do without a prime time game
yeah i mean yeah i think that's what
would concern me too is you know bias
within those communities not being
consistent you know through and through
with how you're evaluating the situation
yeah letting uh
the stage in which the game is played on
affect you letting the team that's
playing
and you know maybe some of their star
players affecting you you know
maybe one week we got the jaguars and
their offensive lines wiped out
and they go oh we can't do that that's
not fair to gardner minchu and the
jaguars blah blah blah
and then the next week the same thing
happens to kansas city chiefs i don't
want that committee going well they got
mahomes and tyree kill in case
they'll be okay he'll figure out how to
manage the game no that would be bs
you know let alone with a bunch of other
factors we could probably throw out
there too if we thought about this more
so
uh yeah they're uh mike you're on to
that one there i think you're right
those those things need to be set forth
right now
uh and it does seem like you know the
nfl is a little scared to do that yeah i
don't i don't deny that i think you're
right there but
i don't know where where this goes going
forward i wish they would throw out a
rule like out there soon or something to
tell us what they're going to do
if a team doesn't be tied to it yeah i
know they don't they don't want to be
tied to see that's the thing yeah
they don't want to have to cancel a
prime time game
on any terms other than their own yeah
right you don't want to have a rule that
ties their hands
yeah and and look this isn't criticism
we're trying to understand how this
sausage is going to get made before they
start
putting it into that the meat grinder
right that's the thing they use the meat
grounder to make the sausage
we're trying to figure out what the
sausage is going to look like before
they've even started to put the
ingredients into the hopper
so i think they don't want to have a
clear set of rules because they don't
want to have their hands tied they won't
have the flexibility to make it up as
they go
but that is the problem i think of doing
it this way and chris one other thing
yeah
acknowledging that the competition
committee members would have conflicts
of interest
opens a box full of pandora because
you think they're going to find a
committee of anybody who doesn't have a
conflict of interest
you think they're going to find a
pristine group of people
who has no friendship who has no
relationship
who has no rooting interest who has no
enemy that
they want to stick it to i mean come on
yeah that's what i would worry about
right
and and so and so whether it's
competition committee members or outside
if they're not going to set aside their
own self-interest
and put something on you know the table
that is in the
interest of the game it's got to be the
best interest of the game so
i just look i think the easiest rule is
this
you have 46 players in uniform and
you know what there have been times
where we've wondered whether or not a
team was even gonna have 46 guys
you show up and play the game and if for
some reason you don't think you're able
to play the game then you forfeit the
game just like the little league team
that shows up with six players
right for a baseball game if you can't
do it you don't do it
there should not be an escape hatch
there should not be a way to postpone
games
that is fair and consistent and it gives
you the ultimate incentive to keep that
virus out of your building that that's
where i'm being that's why i'm behind it
uh you know i am and you know oddly
enough
you know where we look in like social
media and twitter and something
we've gotten really a lot of positive
reaction about that you know as far as
that type of approach but i think that's
the big thing you're right it takes out
bias
and of course is the ultimate incentive
for these teams to continue to battle on
that front too
uh and uh we'll we'll see where it goes
i mean hopefully we'll have an answer or
two here over the next three weeks or so
all right one last thing before we wrap
it up today sean mcdermott getting the
reward that he so richly deserves after
taking the bills to the playoffs twice
in three years when they hadn't been
there since 1999 before his arrival
you know not a lot of details multi-year
extension you never really know until
you can look at the document and there's
so much less transparency when it comes
to paying coaches
than there is when it comes to paying
players but mcdermott has done well and
he's on the front end of what
could be a very successful long-term
career
as coach of a bill's team that may have
an opportunity
to kind of rewind the clock to the early
90s if the patriots have any type of
slippage post tom brady
yeah but yeah and you know the even the
talk of the contract extension for
mcdermott you know
it doesn't get a lot of news kind of
flies into the radar i feel like that's
the bills and sean mcdermott it's kind
of
you know what they are but you know we
gush a lot about sean mcdermott i know i
certainly do and i think
you do as well because you talk about
change of culture
changing a team you know week to week
game plans
mcdermott is as good as it gets with him
and brandon bean up there in buffalo
i mean i i everything i've seen to this
point i go
damn they're they're in the cream of the
crop as you know duo
coach gm's in football for for my money
how quickly they've reversed things
there in buffalo
you know they clearly have a vision and
what they like
to play offs two of the last three years
you know
one with tyrod taylor and then another
one with a second year quarterback and
josh allen
he's a defensive coach and his defense
has been damn special
ever since he's been up there uh so you
know this is this is uh
good to see it really is it's good to
see the good people in football get
rewarded
and i also sit here with this sean
mcdermott contract extension and go
he better get a damn extension if matt
rules gonna make nine and a half million
dollars a year
and hasn't even you know pissed a drop
in the nfl yet yep i said that there we
go yep bam it's friday for me
and sean mcdermott makes the playoffs
two out of the last three years i'm
principal that's just
messed up so you know hopefully
mcdermott got 9.6 million or 10 million
or whatever whatever it is but uh good
to see nonetheless
something we talked about during one of
the breaks today and this is a very real
dynamic
the guys making the most money at the
coaching position in the nfl
we don't know how much they make the
teams do a good job
of funneling money through different
companies and the official number is one
thing but the
real number is a different thing and
it's all about not blowing out the curve
and that's why there's anger and
frustration
that the panthers paid matt rule what
they did because
david tepper blew out the curve right
look this is what this is what happens
when when the pool of available
multi-billionaires
shrinks and there aren't a whole lot of
people who can write the check for a
team
you potentially are going to approve
ownership by a guy who's going to come
in
is going to what the unwritten rules
what's this unspoken agreement right
bullcrap
right i'm trying to win football games
and i know how valuable
a good coach is i mean we've been saying
it for years
you look at how much salary cap space
goes to certain players how much a
quarterback gets
i mean if you've got a quarterback
that's worth 40 million a year bill
belichick's worth 45 million a year
right
right so i mean coaches the good coaches
should be
getting a lot more than they're getting
because they mean a lot more to the
success of the team than the best
players do chris yeah i don't think
there's a
a sport in all the world that can
compare to the importance of an nfl head
coach uh to me it's
it's the the the one the most coach
dependent sport there is
uh that we got out there right now and
you know you're right
and i think a lot of them are a little
bit underpaid but
a lot of them are making a lot more
money than we realize because of yes the
tricks of the trade or whatever how the
owners figure out how to do these
contracts pay them through different
companies
like you said you know pay them a yearly
salary but
they get a bonus that they don't have to
really tell the public about every
january those are how those things go so
yeah we don't know what the top coaches
we were spitballing right we were going
like
i wonder what bill belichick really does
make you know i mean if you made me
guess i'd bet you bill belichick's
making 20 million dollars a year
i would think it's somewhere around
there you know if matt rule's making
nine and a half
and i think we know some other coaches
that we think are somewhere in the 14
15 range i would just think belichick's
probably up there in around 20.
and let me just say this if bill
belichick's making 20 million a year
he's woefully underpaid he's worth so
much more
than that and and and it's all about
keeping the market under control and and
look
there's never going to be a collusion
lawsuit filed by coaches against the nfl
it's not going to happen
but they're vulnerable to it and if you
go back over the years and look at how
the
salaries have gone up for players the
the explosion especially with the salary
cap
and free agency and and the sharing of
the revenue between the
league and the and the players you look
at how that's gone up
and then if you would chart the same
numbers for coaches it's not going up at
the same rate and it should
right but they're doing a good job of
keeping it under control so we won't
know exactly how much sean mcdermott is
making and there's a good chance
whatever it is
he's making more he deserves all of it
as well because there's an opportunity
to knock belichick off of his pedestal
and and who knows
uh you know belichick is still belichick
and i and with cam newton there i still
think they're going to be pretty good
but sean mcdermott's done a pretty good
job of putting himself in number two
position in that division chris and i
don't see that changing anytime soon no
i don't i mean it's the first time in a
while we're actually thinking about
like whoa do we switch the patriots to
number two
i mean i think that says a little
something i mean and even last year
we weren't putting the patriots at
number two we knew they were still
number one and all that
but we did go into the buffalo games
going last year
going like hmm can buffalo buffalo might
be able to beat new england they might
be able to do that they played them
pretty close two times you know
certainly didn't win i understand that
but
uh yeah i think this is the first
legitimate
challenger in the afce since the early
days of rex ryan and the jets there
hasn't been anybody significant since
then
and uh i think mcdermott you know is is
going to be here for a while and and
make a mark on the afc east you know
maybe even after belichick gone i just
expect mcdermott to be the head coach
for a long time
all right that's it for today's pft ot
we'll be back friday for a new edition
of pft live
check out chris sims unbuttoned pf tpm i
haven't done one this week maybe
although i think pftot still becomes
pftpm
i don't know i've been so caught up in
everything that's going on i don't know
what's happening anymore it still does
see if you can get a little work done
this week
okay come on try to do something around
here help out the uh the
you know nbc try to help us out a little
bit please this this streak continues
back to january 1 2004 hashtag no days
off
chris have three days off happy birthday
to
little phil aka the little effort and
uh uh enjoy enjoy your time uh off
although i know you won't be completely
shut down we'll see everybody on friday
have a great day see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports